all right so uh anyone that talks to us
about horror films or watching some of
our reviews knows uh we love the shit
out of the original haunting the black
and white right III not 1999 no uh yeah
B I do not party like it's 1999
no and we are obsessed with it we watch
it every Halloween it just showed it to
Tamara yeah it's probably it's probably
our favorite horror film it's hard to
think of one like action we add her as a
psychological horror film it's not no
it's a lot of your demographic yeah
no no but by any means but even if
you're not scared by it which is many
people that aren't just the psychology
around is just amazing it's incredible
characters it's a gothic story is so
phenomenal uh you can tell this by you
when we reviewed the remake and so forth
so uh we are legion know we got really
excited when we heard there there was a
show done by the guy who did oculus and
Gerald's game about Ouija - surprisingly
more cautiously optimistic cuz when I
heard it was like 10 episodes I'm like
Jesus like the original movies like two
and a half and it's a short book well
and we're gonna do for 10 episodes then
we got the trailer and our like this is
in the haunting like oh this looks good
yeah I'm like what I'm like
I'll keep an open mind but yeah I was in
the similar boat of like I don't know
what what to make of that trailer like
you know so this is getting a lot a lot
of people are talking about this show um
and just as kind of like a horror fan of
this kind of stuff that's a little bit
more psychological a little bit more
what you don't see but they also show
goes to and just because we love the
haunting I figure it'd be good to just
give our thoughts on the show we've seen
the whole thing and I try and even think
well let's start obviously dude let's
start out spoiler free okay I won't be
long I'll get my initial thoughts and
then we'll go into spoilers cuz this
really is one do we say overall first
what we thought overall yeah um let me
okay so if people ask me there's this
great line in The Simpsons and I forget
what spawned it but I believe it's
Reverend Lovejoy some of these
either asking them if God is real or if
they're going to heaven or someone I
think it's like it's got a UH am I doing
wrong against God am I doing wrong
against it and basically Reverend
Lovejoy is this great answerís which was
a well yes with an if no with a but and
long answer short yes so my answer is is
the show good worth watching long answer
yes with an if short answer no with a
but I don't know if you want to go off
that or like oh sure I mean okay and
especially as scary shows work I mean
top of my head I can't even think of a
scary show I've ever seen
honestly like legit scared me and I have
to be a kid in which t Stephen King's it
the original what Tim Curry did a bit
but I was like eleven I think when there
came out yeah it had to be like maybe
one or two x-files until mystery scared
me I haven't seen that that shit's
mostly real yeah America's most was so
that's Gary yeah I was afraid to open
the door intended fiction yeah I can't
think of a show that actually scared me
and this is the first show I can think
of that legit did and not disturb not
made uncomfortable because playing shows
that did that but scared me though
must've both I was very disturbed in
yeah but it it took its to it starts off
a little clumsy
um and I can't just go crazy for 10 M
yeah I'm not gonna I'm not gonna dock it
that much really yeah and it took us a
while to get into the idea that this is
the haunting kind of in the same vein
Bates Motel is you know it's like oh and
I and I I think it's brilliant in
retrospect that's they were like we
can't remake the 1963 film lightning
doesn't strike twice so here's our riff
on the haunting like the Bates Motel is
their riff on psycho it's very much the
themes and ideas everything else is very
loose like all the characters are one
family pretty much yeah you know their
names and stuff but this is like I told
Tamara cuz I had gotten mostly through
the series and she was gonna watch the
original with us and she's like well
shit
wait and I'm like yes it's much but if
you want to see both it's much better to
see the movie first because you can see
what they're doing and there's all these
nods and little Easter eggs and the way
they they retool some of the characters
and use the same names and a cameo that
I thought was really kind of brilliant
so it's definitely if you want to see
both I would actually see the movie
first so you can look at the show and
see okay now I see where they're going I
don't think it works as well the other
way around I think if you see the shows
you might look at the movie like huh but
the other way around I actually that was
pretty yeah what you still can I mean
I'm sure people that see the movie I
agree I think that's a fair way to do
its golly if you're gonna watch Star
Wars you know a screw the prequels
anyway but it's like if you got to watch
it see the original three and then see
the prequels it's like everyone else did
or see the original three then force
awakens and last yeah yeah and then
spend the rest of your days on the
internet complaining about it but yeah
so it's one of those things where it's
like the the psychology is great the the
effects are decent ish they look very
fake but they're heroes they are really
yeah and when they're missed I'm just
kind of like Jesus this is like better
than the 99 haunting but no I uh
and it's one of those shows where the
more you stick with it it gets more and
more disturbing more and more
uncomfortable more and more weirdly real
in some aspect and as a character
high-water mark right in the middle yeah
five six yeah basically if you're on the
fence about it get to Episode five if
after episode five you're like this does
nothing for me then leave I still say
six maybe maybe but I feel like those
two it's like if after episode six
you're like I don't get it
yeah cuz I think five and six are
basically just a high-water mark of the
entire series so it's kind of yeah it
gets really great there but even after
that it's still really good and then
Christ like so many things the ending
just fucked everything sadly that's
where the yes with an if no with a but
yeah where it just goes it seems like
almost 100% against what the show was
doing the whole
time it literally the style is different
the writing is different dialogues
different the characters are different I
can think of nothing no better way to
put it than this show manages to snatch
defeat from the jaws of victory yeah
like that's what it does I'm like you
you had victory and then somehow you
snatched defeat from that yeah so so
that that's a general thought I say see
it I say it's worth checking out
it does have ghosts that you actually
see so it's not like the original heart
thing if you didn't like that about it
but it does have the psychology which is
very very good as well I'd say watch the
first nine episodes make up an ending in
your own head and go that's how it
should end and then watch the other one
and consider that the clew ending that's
how we could have happened this is how
it really happened no no it's it's the
fanfiction ending really what it is cuz
it's like if you if you can get over the
fact that the ending is and I hate using
this word but I'm gonna pull it out
garbage
what is someone's gonna do a supercut of
all the times you say garbage I'm
probably up to five I'm like I think
five times I'm just like no that pissed
me off so much I'm gonna say garbage but
you say garbage like all the time that's
like your favorite word do your tell you
why because trash sounds like more fun
I think trash yeah I think you know a
movie but are garbage garbage that were
flaming dumpster fire if you get over
the fact that the ending is a flaming
dumpster fire then yeah sure watch it
like cuz I mean there's so much great
stuff going into that final episode but
I just did like I just want to warn
people like don't watch the final
episode just whatever you think is gonna
happen in your heads probably better and
that seems to be the everyone kind of
agrees I haven't really I have not seen
a person yet it's just like yeah what's
your problem everybody's just like
they're they either just like this
ending sucks or they're apologists for
it like yeah it really didn't end as
well as it could have but I liked it
like you know I've never seen anybody go
that's what I wanted yeah like nailed it
God and I'm a dozen people so far report
like their thoughts so out of that dad
of 12 people I've got zero we were just
like I liked that ending it's either in
a pot in a pan apology of like yeah I
wasn't really that great but I still
like it overall or that was awful so
that's our initial thoughts I mean I
really highly recommend it um I will say
wouldn't what it does best is the old
Exorcist 3 trick which is it knows how
to set up to the point that sometimes I
don't feel there's enough of a payoff
every once in a while where it'll rely
on like CGI where I'm like no don't but
your council I got Edie but it does this
thing yeah we're at first I didn't like
the jump scares
cuz jump scares to me lava were kind of
it's at the lowest layer yeah it's at
the lowest form of art where it's just
like you just boom like okay so for one
second you're scared but then they after
that you're like how do some stay with
you yeah it doesn't really stay with you
and yet somewhere in Episode two there's
like there's like a funeral scene and
one of the characters is like dressing
up the body and putting the makeup on
it's a close-up of the corpses face and
like I was waiting for it
that was later than - I know Simon - but
I was waiting and waiting and waiting
and I realized that whether or not there
was a jump scare from this or not the
amount of time spent waiting and I won't
give it away but the amount of time
spent waiting one way or another for a
payoff that may or may not come I was on
edge the entire time I was sitting on my
couch - nervously like something's gonna
happen something's gonna happen and it
hit me then in there as much as the jump
scares are occasionally cheap they did
the fucking job because I'm just like
that's well done versus other ones
where's so many of the jump scares I
will say this when the jump scares
happen with rare exception their real
jump scares what I hate the most
love telephone ring oh it's just the
telephone like that kind of like I note
up there okay no here's here's the new
one and this is what this guy is doing
to it every horror director is doing
this so I can't be like too angry but
it's one of those things where it's like
okay this has officially become a
jump-scare and you can see it in the
opening so like you know yeah I think
the kids are awake and the the MA I
think the father is like trying
calm down any leaves I started to track
you on the door and then suddenly you
just hear me just getting in bed but
they magnify that I'm hitting the bed
that sound like boom like it's the
loudest hey person getting a bit and so
that it's a it's a normal everyday thing
turn it up but I have this come up for
as lame as there was and that was a
hundred percent lame I think I could
count on my one hand a number of times
the entire ten episodes did that where
it's like no it's a pointless loud noise
every other jump-scare it's a ghost like
it's something legit where it's like no
that was a legit scary thing that did
that it wasn't just like I'm hopping
into bed really loudly to scare you like
it not bothers me about that cuz they're
trying to act like it's not a jump-scare
like oh we didn't try to scare what
you're showing a guy giving you beds
bullshit
what's worried about that that is a jump
scum and it's a it's a super cheap trick
and honestly until the ending I would
have thought that director was better
than that which is what bothers you it's
what bothers me about the show as a
whole which is this director so gets it
that to see him do cheap shit like that
or cuts that go on too long or effects
that don't work I'm like you're better
than this and you've got to know you're
better than this because you're doing
this so well and it's like I can't tell
if he doesn't have faith in his own
abilities or if he just assumes we're
all idiots and then if he doesn't have
some loud noise or something to get our
attention again we're all gonna be like
the third scurry and turn it off well in
any case it's a lack of faith in either
us or him and it sucks because he's so
good at everything else in this well
here's the other thing too is that part
of me almost thought well maybe like
Netflix or the people making it
producers whatever said know that you
got an assist you yeah yeah but here's
the thing Netflix as far as I can see
doesn't usually do that they'll let
creepy dark disturbing stuff just play
out in their shows and their movies so I
don't know if that would be it it
doesn't sound like it would be he
understands all of it and the one thing
he understood most of all is like cuz
whoo anybody who's had a sudden death
and
family there's like this aura of like
surreal gloom of like shock it's like
shock and awe you're just completely
just like like you just got punched in
the face like what and you wander around
and spoiler somebody dies in there I
think people can't see ya like well it's
a horror thing like the show the
trailers do yeah it's a haunted yeah and
like as like we both went through that
and it captures that weird waking
nightmare realm you just walk around
like a zombie for a few weeks like not
knowing what reality you're even in the
sense of gloom then now we have to do
this this what do we do with the body
what do we do with this there's a
funeral arrangements and then you've
gotta wake you've got a funeral you got
all these things and then when you look
back on it it's like you you hardly even
remember it like it's just this weird
days and it gets that sense of like huge
depression like I have never seen a show
so captured the amount of gloom
something that like that like does to a
person psyche and he completely gets it
and I've never like as a metaphor for
depression or a sudden death in the
family and all the weird things you're
like oh yeah the guilt the denial the
way families like bicker at each other
and snipe at each other the stress you
go through like Jesus he nailed it to
the point that it's like it was hard for
me to watch like I don't want to use the
word like triggering like triggered but
if you've ever gone through something
like that it really just like send you
right back to that kind of like quasi
PTSD of like Jesus Christ like now it's
all coming back like the shit I remember
it's like like that's a huge
accomplishment and probably one of the
best things he did in this well what I
like too is that they cut back and forth
between them being kids and them being
adults and even if they didn't do that
the acting and the writing is so good in
this and I feel like you get their
connection you know what they're like
cuz they're actually very different as
kids honestly than they are at all so
anyway so even seeing we could tell the
effect that there it's very Stephen King
said this honestly this owes much more
in my opinion to Stephen King than to
Shirley Jackson it gets a lot of the
Shirley Jackson bits right like it has a
lot of the same themes but like it's
almost like you
wanted to make a Stephen King movie
right and until the ending did it like I
think this is a better version of
Stephen King's it Ord The Shining than
we've gotten in any iteration like in
the last shiny or the last it was like
funhouse fun but it was kind of like
dark funhouse like you got the clown
right around this is just gloomy and
depressing and spooky and disturbing and
fucking relentless with it it never lets
up like at the end of episode 6 I was
binging it like three episodes that time
I'm just like I like put the controller
down I'm like I need a break go outside
I got to get some sunshine I got to
watch some motherfucking cartoons this
is like just playing with my mind like
so I I thought it was absolutely
brilliant 14:08 was one of the few
movies I thought it at your might this
one remind me a lot of 40 no a witch is
a king story and it's the same thing
where it is just it's mostly one room
there's not really too many monsters
it's more what's in this guy's head and
Canady with the past and I know where
you are and stuff like that and laws and
things like that so it's one of those
things where it's like when you said
that I'm like yeah so thanks don't mind
me a lot 14 I got to see that movie I
was a very go outside of that one I
think this is the and I know it's not
Stephen King degli but this is the
darkest Stephen King thing I've seen and
the most tragic probably outside a pet
cemetery which i think is his frickin
scariest yeah where it's just like no
this is just relentless this is this is
dark I remember I think Stephen King
said he didn't even think it would get
published cuz he thought it was so dark
and he was like man isn't happy or
anything it's like this it's like this
is in that same realm of just like this
is what Stephen King would be if like
you really just turned everything up to
11 and like pulled out all the stops and
like I I think it's brilliant I kind of
want and I know
Gerald's game's really good too that's
another king like I kind of hope this
guy becomes a Stephen King of death I
would love if he kept doing King I would
kill I you know I will say this I would
kill to see this guy's version of The
Shining but we just got it it's the
haunting of Hill House yeah it's very
much more shining in many ways in some
ways in the haunting which I mean
Stephen King ripped off Shirley Jackson
too he quoted the haunting I think in
Salem's Lot so I guess it has gone full
circle
which is fine I'm not blinking it's like
you rip off the masters and you pay
tribute and so this has gone like but by
three ways now Shirley Jackson the King
to this get what is this guy's name Mike
oh I see though jump do it so you can
only take the guy you director doc you
I think it's Mike Flanagan Mike could be
wrong just I'm doing it I'm probably
wrong but I think that's is I'm not a
horror excerpt but I I will say this I'm
looking at Baptist cuz this is a name
now I'm going to frickin it's always
there's so many directors out there that
ka I just read this is one now I'm like
no this is entering my brain is if I see
this guy's name on something good or bad
no matter what I think of the ending to
this I'm like I got to see what his
films gonna be no I can't wait I think
that's like one I think it's like his
first film or whatever that I haven't
see and I've seen all those others
because I just loved this guy and then
the the characters like it the biggest
shock to me was I thought this is always
the failing of well they're never as
good as the book there never is they're
on par with the book and I mean it's not
the world's greatest accomplishment cuz
you got ten hours to flush it out but
yeah half hour film but the fact that he
didn't go for cheap I thought was is
kind of an accomplishment cuz I thought
they fleshed out a lot of the carrots
particularly Theo Nell to me is a
lateral move it's a little different but
I'm like it's about on par with the Nell
in the original movie but Theo in
particular and Luke I thought we're both
way more fleshed out in this they have a
backstory you can see where they're like
the only one that does that doesn't feel
is fleshed out to me is their version of
dr. Markway and this is Steve yeah he
was having character but yeah feel and
Luke in particular because like that's
always an issue some people like to
bring up with the original film is that
Theo is a lesbian but she's kind of a
predatory character and people like well
we care like the film but it's like 1963
fact that you got a lesbian in that
movie at all is amazing and they're all
terrible get like my promise they're all
terrible characters in the original
they're flawed people appear in a
haunted house to get see to me that
there's
reason she is kind of like predatory too
is that you know Eleanor does have like
this connection with her this friendship
maybe even kind of this room man they're
like you don't know what's going on
there nope I'm also saying that like you
know then then they have to share room
when she has this you know idea that
maybe she is and stuff and they're
always together like they're always
arguing with shit is going on it's just
even more uncomfortable not as nice
person may want you yeah and you don't
necessarily why them or do you it's
really bad combo if Nell is really naive
and like a toddler basically just
impetuous has these delusional fantasies
I know and I want and this and that and
is all over the place and that's not a
good combo for Theo who probably thinks
well I can fix her I can you know do
this but at the same time there's a part
of you it's like Theo come on you gotta
know this about now but this is some
poor girl that have been completely
sheltered and you can't just you're in
the position of power here why all of
them like Hewson had terrible qualities
about even Markway is like has got some
babies like people type homosexual to be
a predatory character you could be
straight gay bi whatever people like
that exist it's like well I can't watch
a movie because the gay characters kind
of predatory and that just didn't play
well in 1963 because it fed into a
stereotypical yes but it was also 1963
and as a character study it is
interesting I think the movies failure
is that field never got fleshed out in
what made Theo Theo hmm she kind of
shows up I think it's implied in the 63
version that she was in the middle of a
breakup that's about it but yeah you
don't get a whole and this one it's a
similar character like she very much is
like just one night stand with any girl
that shows up it seems but it gives you
the whole reason like it basically tells
you how she ended up at this point where
she likes to close people off or just
get what she wants and then bolt and why
she doesn't make an emotional connection
with anybody how her psychic kind of
powers feed into that I I was really
surprised it's like they took great care
into it way more than I thought in the
original film where it haven't been on
the radar it's 1963 and they got four
characters into our
to do this is like here you go and it's
not like we can just run around and keep
saying she's a lesbian because God knows
it's 1963 and whoa Jerry you like you
know one of the I'll say is yours I'll
say this before we get into spoilers
there's because I don't think it's
really spoils mine you think but there's
one episode and you're all gonna know if
you say you'll know which one it is
where it's not all done in one shot but
there's very few cuts in it and there's
a lot of directors who like to show off
that they can do something in one shot
it don't matter there's lots a reason to
do something in one shot but it does get
a little gimmicky after a while and what
I realized with this one is that I feel
like this one could sort of brought it
to a new level because a lot of this
episode just takes place in a funeral
home is just people interacting off each
other
and it feels like a play and I mean that
in the best sense where you feel like
you're in the room with them and the
tension just builds so much more when
you feel you're one of the people
witnessing this and that's what was
messing with my head I'm just like this
feels like things I've gone through
funerals and I'm just like oh I am NOT
having fun reliving this and it ups the
scares as well because there's there's
two kind of major scares that that kind
of like got us in this a one has to do
with buttons again we won't give it away
but then another it's just a light going
off I mean talk about the most unscary
thing cliche you could do both in the
room but way but the tension is so great
and rising and sometimes there's
something in the background sometimes
there's not watch the background of the
show by the way there's a lot of snow
spotted things that I missed it's like
yeah there's a statue that moves I'm
like I never saw it yeah that's
brilliant his turn they're even I missed
it that's good cuz that means you could
watch it again they don't do that Sean
there's like a lost of in the band so
watch the background uh and that episode
has a few of them too but like the
biggest scare is they're all yelling and
Ezra and then just the light goes off
and just like I was watching my wife and
we both went oh shit like it's just
going off but it's like you are so in
that room
you're so with these people and it's so
uncomfortable in the tension and you're
just it's just amazing so simple as that
I'd be like that's the hot button spit
was actually my favorite scare it did
you didn't see anything there's no Chun
there's little loud but the idea is
whether somebody did it or whether a
ghost did it mm-hmm
it's really creepy and disturbing either
way like it's just very unsettling there
is no out and that's what this there's
no so it's just night either way yeah
because like if somebody did it how
fucking twisted and disturbed is that
like that is messed up and that's what
this show really does visually speaking
there is no the word I want to use a
safe space I guess you know how horror
films they'll be like kind of a safe
space where they always they go for
classic things like the corner there's
the dark corner ooh something's gonna be
there there's the locked door someone's
gonna be behind their it exorcist the
room yeah and then when you when you
when you turn off Netflix and then you
go to your bedroom or whatever it's like
well there's just the dark corners you
don't look into or you don't look in the
closet or you're fine this one there's a
character in bed or on a couch opens
their eyes and something's staring at
them from the ceiling it removed one of
the last like visual safe spaces like
that's when you're going to fucking
sleep yeah and like samples in your eyes
they can be yeah and when you open your
eyes it's right there I'm like that's
amazing that's terrifying like because
it removes all of those places that you
think oh you're okay even when you're
like I've heard reports of people is
this like I can't sleep now because of
this damn thing it's like I didn't have
that problem it's so brilliantly - yeah
then sleep oh yes - oh yes yeah like I
didn't have problems getting to sleep
but it definitely the the gloom of it
definitely it was like watching grave of
the fireflies I just felt like I'm just
in a funk for a few days afterwards I'm
just like just depressing like but I
mean that's good if it could do that
like it has a real emotional effect yeah
so we should well I said we were gonna
probably talk shortly without spoiling
but we went a while so let's just jump
into spoilers now so see you get the
gist of what
we liked about about what we don't like
about it so now we gotta go on to
spoilers let's you want to start the
things we did like the other spoilers
like Oh most episodes 5 the ending of 5i
I figured it out I think near the end of
4 I didn't figure it out I figured out
what they were doing I didn't know how
they were gonna do it but I started to
put it together and that's not a problem
because if you execute something really
well I don't care if but I think for
most people might be a twist but the
idea that she's haunting herself is one
of the most brilliant things I've ever
seen on anything ever in a horror
because it sets up that she's been
haunted by this thing and she can't get
away she goes to the house and the
brilliance of that scene - of whether
she's consciously trying to kill herself
or whether a ghost a ghost of her mother
or whatever is making her do it it's
super creepy either way and you never
the you never quite know what exactly is
going on but the idea that this is like
well this is it she hangs herself and
the idea that it's over like one way or
another release and then that awful
realization when she sees all of the
members of her family and then she sees
her face now you know the significance
of no no no no no no no okay that was
creepy enough hearing that no no no the
significance of it went on top of that
just the image the idea of being that
person seeing all that is terrifying
than just the image of her being bent
like that
you know with the neck and everything
but still looking around like she's
still alive on like she feeling the pain
and everything and not knowing what's
coming back so fucking horrifying that
is that is as close to a definition of
Hell as I can think of I wear it I
turned it off I'm just like oh my god I
need a minute they're like a stiff drink
cuz I'm just like that is that is the
most nightmarish thing I can think of
and then when she's sitting there like
this is must be will oh yeah at the end
of six race you say that's a creepy idea
to where you just kind of disappear and
nobody sees you and what a creep and
you're glad here I'm here and nobody
sees you're wrong yeah it's such a great
metaphor for depression like where it's
like
go inside it smells like depressive
people will hide things and you'll never
know you know it's like but nobody heard
me or you might think you're trying them
and maybe people are ignoring and even
these are not some phone and they didn't
pay attention yeah it's like it's such a
great metaphor for that and I'm just
like wow this all tied together
brilliantly and I'm just like that's
just the most one of the most primordial
conceptions of like just hell in the
afterlife words like and now you just
get to relive it and you're the ghost
and you're haunting yourself so there
was no escape at all
you're now fucking trapped I thought
that was brilliant the way they
reinterpreted some things were like the
knocking on the funeral home yeah I was
doing it I couldn't believe how well
that worked
love that seeing the original haunting
and we're just like well how can you
redo as it goes or is it just kids like
it still seems a little nebulous the
sound of a jet was so good things are
kind of shaking too and just the timing
of the hits and everything I was like I
couldn't believe how effective that the
most of like well the worst scenes and
the whole thing when mr. crane walks in
and sees no as a little girl in the
coffin oh yeah oh my god that was the
yeah I'm just like alright where's the
razors like this is me yeah yeah and
again they're great visual metaphor it's
like what parents who said to bury their
child whether they're an adult or not
hasn't felt like that it's just awful
it's as I said it captures that
nightmarish quality of like when a
sudden death happens and your brains
just like grow and again from a
technical level is so much of that was
done in one shot that when he's walking
towards the casket he's creepy because
the person you saw before isn't in there
it takes a second for you to see who's
in there because it's slowly going up to
the same thing with the buttons and then
when you see the kid that is both like
oh let's creep because some we didn't
think was gonna be in there it's a kid
and that's oh it's his interpretation of
who's in there as a child it's just this
you want so many painful level and I
always like I know the jump scares and
the scene in the car with no good no
that's yeah that boo like it's good but
the buttons was my favorite cuz like
just hearing that shout from Cheryl in
there and
build up and that build up and then when
you see the buttons which is super
creepy and then it's like who did this
who and you realize that no matter what
either answers bad either one of the
family members did it in which case
Jesus Christ fuck is wrong with you and
that's bad and super creepy or a ghost
in it the ghost of the mother did it or
and then when the lights go off and that
corpse with the buttons is just there
hmm and then when the coffin tips over
like just everything about that episode
was just super cool it always builds on
so much of the scares which I liked
argue the jump scares uh it builds on
where nurses are emotional I'm just
saying no no but but it builds on their
emotion like every single time something
happens it feels like well yeah that
reflects what they're going well the
jump scares
what the haunting it yeah the jump scare
would know in the car worked because I
think she was trying to get their
attention I feel like there was no like
like stop arguing like that was what I
got out of it kind of like its to snap
them out of this like you know nonsense
of here's a scene remind me of something
something else this show does
surprisingly well that I usually hate in
both movies and shows but I can't
believe how many times they got away
with that really worked until the ending
is that they give as so may these
characters have monologues they're not
speeches their monologues and they go on
for a long time and as part they were
yeah and because ka I was like yeah but
you know but because the writing is so
good and the acting is so good you
really listen and they go on what seems
like the perfect amount of time for them
to get out what they need to get out cuz
you feel in this whole show
it's a melding up that was Steve's best
moment to the one moment where I thought
that character came I always like dad
it's called mental illness yeah like we
all and I'm just like that's what a good
horror story does it's like maybe he's
right
yeah like we're all kind of seeing this
through their points of view maybe they
just see and shit cuz they're all nuts
like who knows like you know and he says
like she went off her meds and you know
this is what happens in it until the end
it remains pretty open-ended um the mrs.
crane that is what Jack Torrance should
she's this nice sympathetic character
who goes it mad hmm and like I was
really wrapped up in it and I'm just
like this is a better version of Shining
than any version of The Shining I
thought was Steven Weber in the
miniseries
I thought he was more sympathetic but I
didn't find it very scary nah this one
was way more tragic to watch and when
she bashes the mirror and you gotta see
it from was a Theo's point of view where
she just huh yeah Steve's point of view
who ever was when she bashes the mirror
and from the poor kids maybe it's like
mom's gone crazy like all the kids you
could see that just like mom's going
crazy like in this poor woman and the
the whole thing with the flapper I
thought was more interesting than
anything in the shining with the bubblin
like you must correct them I thought her
speech about like no you just gotta wake
them up yeah was so much creepier
because we we used to live in a city
where a woman did this she basically
suffocated her three children and
thought she was doing right and the
husband and everything was basically
like no put her in an institution she's
nuts it's postpartum depression she's
but this shit happens
like and it's way more scary to me than
like the Herrera with an axe and just
hacking the dead verses like no come
kids tea party time you're with the big
wait no you're Lee into a better plays
it's just kind of Colton way more my
it's like a way more psychological and
way more scary to me because that shit
happens all the time
way more than 40 whacks with the wet
noodle like those are the ones that get
the headlines but people killing their
kids and just thing or postpartum
depression or like the weirdness that
good like that's real like and like that
whole kind of word was going near the
end I'm saying this is just way creepier
this is like everything that those type
of stories do turned up to 11 and the
particularly did you know this in the
flapper her character they did this
weird color effect where in the old days
used to have like our aunts and uncles
have one from one we would think that
sort of those light brown it's not not
sepia tone it's actually they take
black-and-white pictures and then they
color them in with like pastels or
paints yeah you know everything looks
pastel they did that with her and I'm
just like this is really unnerving
the corpse ship didn't know like suck
she's like I'm a
so who scares like could have cared less
about that that was bullshit but when
they had her in just that weird pastel
tone like she was an old photograph and
the whole room had that kind of old
photograph feel and the way just you
couldn't really tell what was really
like everything just was starting to
blend and like her whole mind was
turning into this nightmare realm until
at the very end she's just like no this
is the dream I'll wake them up like it's
just I'm just like this is a mindfuck
this is Satoshi Kohn shit like that man
the realism what's real what's a dream
well this guy does this a lot of this
director will have stuff happening you
know in the present in the pan in the
past and they're constantly being
haunted by the past and you don't know
if they're real or if they're you know
in the person's mind oculis you know a
lot of that too about the past and not
be able to control your body which I
love how both this and the haunting
really tight I guess in some respect
Gerald's game to where you don't have
control over your body and you're doing
right yeah yeah your mind or evil what
else husband I said she's just seeing it
I was like oh my god once again does the
best nightmares well even the mother
what when yeah like you know she has
this whole fantasy and she wakes up and
she's holding a screwdriver to her
husband and Jesse idea of not having
control not being aware what you're
doing is so terrifying such a creepy
idea that's what I love his movies and
it are like that another best scare was
not he's chasing after his wife in the
hallways that didn't get me much but
what gabby is when the kids started
screaming Alec whatever you know the
stairs and he's upstairs and the lights
are out and he has to run as fast as he
can it was it yeah that's primordial
terror like those are the best scenes in
there where it's just like and then you
get other scenes with like there were so
many scenes where I just want this just
yell cut just cut like the floating man
mmm
what an awesome idea what a great effect
and the yeah in the hallway I thought it
was pretty cool it's like you see a lot
by I'm like no it's still cool Luke goes
under the bed I'm like okay and then you
see the feet the feet come in and the
cane I'm like a kid this is brewing and
I'm like terrified and I'm terrified and
I'm just like okay
cut or I'm like maybe cut too Luke
screaming cut or maybe you just see the
bedspread lift a bit yeah cut but no we
have to do fold these come in and I'm
just like what are you doing yeah no it
does scare ruined before we get the
ending I just wants a real quick because
we're in this point erequest Tamblyn as
the psychiatrist was a nice - yes again
say you're nuts you're nuts nothing else
is real um but the Moses character in
the original yeah exactly the end but
some of the scares you might have missed
there in the background well one is in
the funeral home you see now a couple
times they're so tight just in the
background though like that yeah there's
a weird invokes in Luke and Nels bedroom
when they're kids I swear there's a dude
standing in the corner in a hoodie a
poster but I can't I don't like this all
good
it's pretty brilliant if it's just a
poster cuz I'm like it's out of focus
I'm like I can't tell if that's
something just supposed to be in the
room like a poster of a basketball
player he's something or the episode I
think it's one episode but but the
episode focusing on the mother and what
she sees everything from her point of
view that there's two great scenes one
is that she goes in the road she goes in
the kids room and there's the two
statues there they're facing that when
she goes in the room she comes out the
statue suddenly looking at her so keep
an eye out for that I know that when I
miss it and another one where I
literally just went holy shit and my
wife just went what what and I'm like
don't you see that don't you see is that
it sound like hits from is she comes
into it's not the kitchen I thought
maybe it is the kitchen and the kids are
like eating the sandwiches or something
like that I think mrs. delis there too
and the mother comes in again after
seeing something and just in the
reflection there is this ghost of a
woman no eyes just watching them and
it's just in the background and the
mother comes in the camera changes and
go a little bit so that just these
probably the been neck leaving there
with the no eyes I don't know or
anything it was an actor so so you just
see like this I so then the camera moves
they just see the eyes still watching
that little black eye watching them
and I'm just telling my wife she's nice
um the Dudley's by the way I again like
a little every bird that's the only
thing to get right in every version yes
900 otherwise I'm fine yeah I like to
double using this they're not quite as
spooky but they have more character yeah
there's more sympathy and understanding
to them which I'm okay with
I still mine with they're still the
Dudley's okay is the symbolism of I
loved the reoccurring symbolism one
thing we didn't mention is the cats and
it didn't hit me until later when the
mother was going mad yeah the kittens
well the symbolism of the bug coming out
like it's a corpse and now and then when
the bug comes out of now the mother cat
abandoning the kid yeah I didn't realize
that till later when the mother was
going nuts I'm like now I get it with
the kittens like well they can't survive
without their mother I'm like and now
the whole theme ties together it was
foreshadowing it like it's brilliant
taking the kitten for still being a lie
but it's something again which is a
nightmare like this is just horrific and
then you cut to her working on Nell and
there's always this like and you keep
expecting Nell's eyes to open yeah or
something um that scene by the way I
remember turning to my wife we're
watching that I'm like I'm getting
cremated if you really want just the
bizarreness of what we the unnatural
things we do to the human body after we
die like watch episode 2 was it episode
2 of this where she does that no I
really think it's later on it's like
whenever it is and it's just like 5 it
could be - yeah and it's just I'm just
like I don't get it just burn me up man
yeah this is Egyptian we're just a class
by yourself
yeah and it really gets into the
nitty-gritty of what it's like and I did
love that one line though where it's
just like we haven't done this ourselves
we get into that like hey we're going
through shit in our family you can
fucking deal by doing us this one or two
favors yeah like and my favorite line is
where he's like I've got my hands in my
sister's chest cavity removing her
organs cuz that's what happens with an
autopsy so you can go fucking pick Luke
up or whatever it was she was asking him
to do and I'm like that that really felt
real where it's just like you
do this and got shit to deal with in a
lesser show I would have said her doing
you know being the Undertaker for her
would just be preposterous that would be
so stupid no sister would do that better
care but it totally made sense not only
with our character but I could almost
see any of them they had the occupation
doing that because they didn't know what
was real and especially came to the dead
and this is something where you would
look down be like no I'm doing this so
that I can see bit by bit
this person has gone like this is almost
her closure one it was her she was the
one with the kittens right
I thought those Theo was it the I could
be wrong no I think it was Shirl because
I thought that's how it all tied
together was in the mother in Chevy well
that's a shame that that's her first
experience with death it's like you can
see I thought that was the idea you
could you might be right you could see a
beginning they're like looking at the
kittens body alright your first
experience with corpse and then what the
bug comes out of Mel's mouth so that has
to be yeah you're right you're right
yeah so it's like you could see how she
became a mortician after like um I think
we showed it especially with how much
battery low we got a little bit but
still let's let's talk about the ending
do it so with this you warned me you
tried to warn me I did warn you I did
warn me ahead of time
I'm like Galvez he's pretty good I'll
tell you I'll tell you what this is
there was this football game like it was
Michigan this is a college football game
Michigan versus the other Michigan State
and their big rivals this is the big
things of like a European soccer fan or
whatever imagine two big rivals and at
the very end all Michigan needed to do
was kick the ball away and they they had
won they were they were points ahead and
this and that and and the area is ready
to go home and there is in they were
like five seconds left or something
crazy and yeah they they blew it somehow
the beer team got it yeah the kicker the
kicker missed or something in there's
chaos the other team came scored and won
the game and there was this shot to the
crowd and there was this one kid yeah
I'll send you the pictures put it I'll
tell you about put it up right now that
Shire it's right there it's called the
surrender Cobra that's what they call it
and that look at that basically that is
when all life has been snuffed out of
the universe that is when all hope has
been bludgeoned to death right before
your eyes just look at his face then
look just says I don't know what the
hell I just saw I can't even comprehend
it but I don't like it
okay so he'd take the picture down why
am I telling you this
because that was the exact look on my
face for the entire last episode I have
my arms over my head my jaw was hitting
the ground my eyes were open I was just
going what the fuck what and and let me
just let me just practices
I had a Michigan Michigan State I don't
care I'm just using that as an example
you may use your own example of Mo and
I'm from Chicago this happens all the
time the Cubs had a hundred years of
doing this too recently the Sox the
Bulls the Bears whatever Cleveland knows
good because their experience with the
Cubs whatever team you like Europe
across the world are playing board games
idioms that are that moment in your life
where everything seems to be going right
and you're like I've won I've got it
I've got it I've got it and then all of
a sudden sucker punch that was the
ending to the haunting so post your own
in the comments if you have an example
this was I it I did it it reminds me a
lot of AI to a play nothing else even
quotes we said the same no that's what
kills even never had a birth that's
alright so I sat there when they're
doing the birthday cake thing I
literally sat there on my couch I said
but David never had a birthday and then
when you were watching it you texted me
but David never had a birthday and I'm
like oh my god we think alike well
what's so funny about this really bad
ending is it starts off super fan
fiction II and then it's like the
characters with his wife the wife is
pregnant they're back together
everything's fine and he's writing his
next book is brighter and immediately
like well I don't like this and then
they do the real dirty trick of
saying oh no no no it's not gonna be
that easy we're not doing that
we gotcha and then they get it they were
saying no no we're you're not getting
out that easily where this is the dark
gritty adult shit and it's gonna be hard
to get there and then there's like no
they did give us that shit to quote the
Godfather it insults my intelligence and
it insults the intelligence of the
director as far as I'm concerned I don't
know what made him do this so pretty
much what I mean you've actually seen it
and here's the thing I've been talking
about this to a couple friends who are
also critics and one who still likes the
show and I'm on the fence now about
whether I love the show overall now
because the ending wrecks so much of it
for me but there are three it's like a
one-two-three punch and had it only gone
with one of these things I might have
been able to overlook it it just builds
and builds the first worse and worse
unnecessary goddamn twist of oh no they
killed the Dudley's kid what what what's
that head waiting we'll see you and have
we seen this kid before even no I mean
you did she came out of nowhere and was
with the Tea Party it's because the boy
would say she's really but this weird
thing where it's like it's just is she
real or is she a ghost it's like no she
was mild and now she's dead and this
leads to as if it couldn't be bad enough
that the father just walks in and sees
after finding out there's poison and it
stops them right before they sip it but
no we had to do this because like that's
what kills me it's like the actual
reality is bad enough you didn't need an
extra twist that's awful she's a fucking
killer children but Rob it's it's okay
the does be frank gotta tell everybody
yeah so you do this the kiss dies and
that's where I lost my shit the Dudley's
come in and he's like I'm burning this
house to the ground no you can't because
our ghost child is here so like what and
then and then the the payoff with the
Dudley's apparently is he brings mrs.
Dudley back at the end we made it here
now we die here and I'm just like I
would never want to go back to that
goddamn psycho her ghost baby there too
and I'm just like well where is that
ghost baby what that goes to look like
exactly and okay you don't want to burn
down this house this house has claimed
so many people this house you won't go
to in the night in the dock you won't go
back to it but your kid is there so what
they do come back to it now cuz the kid
is there if they don't burn I would
fucking hire an exorcist to move their
ghost child on and then say hopefully we
will meet in heaven because I'm not
eating in this house that Ghost child
trapped there with all the other creepy
ass goes there like terrible doing
horrible thing would you want to burn
that so the ghost can move on to
whatever the afterlife and they made a
cry I mean I would have been like okay
but they just treat it like it's some
happy a heartfelt yeah she's here
instead pointless Twist number one for
what was something that we all knew like
that basically what I thought that
Arabella who gives us what they were
setting up and what I thought was gonna
happen is dad killed mom because mom
went nuts which is fine and you could be
like ooh that's predictable so what
that's what everything's leading tune if
you executed right it's a horrible
tragic story and dad never got over it
and it like makes sense why he will not
hide it from the cops like maybe he
didn't do it in cold blood maybe of a
self-defense but that would have made
sense twist to the room is also the tree
house and the game room and the Oh
capers
why why is that a big shark I don't know
what no it's about interpreting things
and seeing them as different than but
it's it's not even that scary like twist
three isn't even a twist it's just it's
a happy ending like it was about
Redemption and Luke never had a birthday
and now they get to say their that's
really okay I will say this mm-hmm
I did like cuz of how relentless this
show is and how fucking full of gloom it
is I get his need the directors need to
have like a catharsis of some sort but
not not this yeah I do that they
apologize to now for not believing her
that was necessary I think in any
version that needs to be in there but
the way they handled it
what God the way the way Nell just like
recites Doctor Who lines like I only
thought time was linear but it's a
wibbly-wobbly thing and here's how the
house works in blah blah blah it's like
a giant TARDIS and like like what what
one but stop explaining things you've
taken out all the spooky shit all of it
no even the writing is different because
it goes from people talking okay people
talking and sometimes giving monologues
but but opening us to just speech after
speech after speech everyone is giving a
damn speech about the meaning of life in
this and that's not how they say I'll
give us the M sweets rather meaning and
they're all optimistic positive and now
mommy and daddy walk off together into
the light and then everybody's all like
the family's fixed now as if this wasn't
the worst traumatic horseshit that
they're probably gonna take decades to
get over still and then Luke's alive
that lie look at liars boots line
anything all the dead bodies and they're
like no he died but he came back
oh we whatever a CPR did back there why
were we seeing that guy from the future
than you persons that didn't bother me
if the idea is that all this happens and
they have to somehow save Luke I'm like
okay there's your kind of little out of
like we need help there is no out now
you can't escape it that's the heart you
can't escape that that's what's so
creepy about the haunting I don't
entirely disagree but there's a middle
ground which is I think they can bring
Luke back but also make it creepy but
the thing is that final line where I
literally went back but we oh fuck fuck
together fuck fuck fuck fuck fuck that
fuck that like I cuz I'm already
watching this game more more angry zazz
going on and then just when that final
line hit with the nice music the little
guitar goin and everyone's a Hill House
and he says to all the lines you know a
darkness laid against the wood of Hill
House but it's done in a nice soothing
little way oh it's so comforting I'm
already so angry because these words do
not belong and then they change just the
line of the haunting and those who
walked
their walk alone and they change it too
and we end the file line of the
hauntings and we who walk here walk
alone so creepy and the haunting got it
and it's and we who walk here walk
together I just and I got so fucking
angry you know what you guys show ya
know I'll just send this as a screenshot
but actual evidence of what our
conversation was we walk together but we
want together are you fucked I was so
angry and cuz it's like it's really it's
like a real haunting it's a slow burn
it starts off just kind of dumb and they
you just you're not aware it's getting
worse and worse and dumber and dumber
and just totally missing what this makes
it was doing the critical mistake of the
shining which is redemption stories
aren't scary they never will be scary
and if you hinge too much of it on the
redemption part and there's a happy
ending you have sucked all the scares
out of it in the beginning this is a
problem I have loosely with the sixth
sense which I think tells you early
enough what's going on that it's okay
cuz you watch it again and it's not
scary because it's like okay you you
know what's going on and this is about
the psychological that is not what they
are setting up here and that is not what
they are doing and that is the problem
with it this should have had an ending
more like the others which is in my
opinion the better sixth sense it has an
ending that's dark as hell
much like the original haunting hasn't
anything that's dark as hell but there
is still some release there is still
some comfort even though it's still dark
creepy unsettling there's that one knew
how to tow a nine and and get the best
of both worlds if they did something
like the others I think you would have a
little bit your levity a little bit of
something nice it still be creepy
alright let's do this let's fix the
movie okay do your cliff note version
yeah did you do okay first of all no
that shit with the Dudley's like it and
the Dudley's kid died I say instead
you've ever lost one kid don't
don't throw another one yeah I I say
instead like he kills her maybe in
self-defense
maybe the Dudley's have a reason for not
wanting it to be burned down maybe maybe
instead of a baby that died there one of
their kids died there and their kid was
all denied and it can't something that
happens like ocula or they see it ghost
like then they're like don't burn it
down and then they agreed they'll
testify on cranes behalf and say that no
she was already dead they saw it he
didn't kill her because they know she
was crazy - boom that problem solved
part two
instead they all fall asleep they all
have their different visions and stuff I
didn't mind dad I thought when that was
going that route I'm like okay this
isn't yeah like that's okay
and even having a little reason so he's
sealed off it's like okay which by the
way that room it's not scary
babe they all have a vision and they're
in that one room and instead of Mel
fucking telling them everything maybe
they put it together like can't you feel
it like the heartbeat like this is the
heart of the house or something just
throw out a couple ideas about it and
then they see now and Luke's they're
dying and they all apologize to Nell
Nell can't speak Nell doesn't say
anything she's still that'd be great if
she was still bent it's still kind of
creepy I don't have any time I don't
even need but I do I think that'd be
like so much Saturday you know what I
don't even need that I I could see her
just as normal now but like have that I
love that bit where Luke's just like I
can't go on without you I can't do this
have her whisper something to Luke then
they all wake up and then they leave and
then they talk about it after the fact
and they're all like yeah well we all
had different dreams bah bah bahs of
this and that but they all realize like
something out of explorers but wait a
second we all had kind of the same
ending to our dream is that weird so did
they dream it or was it really real
we're the ghosts real who really fucking
knows but then at the end I would have
sure all the fucking mortician going
like you know because maybe seems like
well I mean that's happy because now all
seems like now moved on and and and
maybe their dad died or whatever moved
on it's like but maybe she could be like
yeah but where were we go he's like what
do you mean we're all right here yeah
but when we die where do we go
what was it Nell said to Luke
and Nels tells Luke you know like they
reveal that we always need to stick
together Tong Tong Tong so are they
gonna go back to the house is this their
doom hmm or are they gonna move like
then you have that final line walks
together and that's like it's mad at
other feeling nice and mojo like that's
kind of so you have the one out where
it's just like okay maybe they'll be
happy but to be stuck in this house who
knows or maybe they'll go I'll move on
like you don't know instead of just
fucking spelling everything out like
we're fucking two years old like this
what's the thing - it spells out yeah
the ghosts were real it was all yeah
absitively yeah uh well and it just goes
against what the show is doing engine
even if you were to take away this is
based on the haunting which in some
respects it's not easy to do because it
is so different but if you're to take
that just feels it doesn't feel like
what the rest of the show was doing the
rest of show was so heavy and so dark
and so adult and so harsh and difficult
and you go for bittersweet it was just
sweet yeah let's do it up sweet you just
can't
yeah and like I said it's one of those
where it was a slow burn it was like sir
pissing me off more and more because I
didn't start off immediately hating it
cuz it maybe look like oh no we're not
gonna do that we're not gonna do the
happy I think we just tricked you some
way alright so this is kinda slow burn
that just got worse and worse and worse
and I'm like and hot and then your thing
for me which is it is objectively better
than the 99 film like it did doesn't
deserve to lick the 99 finish it but in
a way you mean the 99 film doesn't
deserve to like yeah yeah the 99 yeah
the 99 film just is a piece of crap but
in a weird way I found this more
disappointing in the 99 film ten minutes
in you know you love your crap yeah
bleep total flaming dumpster fire
garbage trash this one to go nine
episodes and just think how amazing this
is and then just get garbage thrown in
your face I feel like
got the rug pulled out from under me it
it honestly was in a weird way more
disappointing that's where it's so hard
to be like well do you recommend it I
yes with an if no with a but I like a
lot of movies I mean you just say yeah
but the ending sucks like people have do
you recommend loss I'm like yeah just
keep in mind you're probably not gonna
get a very satisfactory resolution but
still get characters this don't get
suspense it's still you know a kind of
interesting mystery it's just but yeah
like everyone you're really pissed off
at the end it's that it's that football
game like I just and I again know that I
I married into this sick rivalry thing
because of my in-laws but I don't care
one way or another I will say this so if
you're a Michigan fan I only bring it up
because now you know how I you have my
condolences on that one night because
I'm like holy shit nothing I never went
to either universities I don't care but
that that is the feeling I had of just I
get why it was done because it is giving
this levity to something that was so
heavy but I'm with you here to do it you
gotta do not like that theater you
either gotta do all dark no hope sorry
motherfucker that's life that's death or
you know and make that truly scary cuz
that's what we're live earlier a scary
fire or you do a bittersweet you know I
actually even crave the fireflies two
summers that is a bittersweet yeah it is
a bitter sweet ending the way it ends
there there is that glimmer of hope and
it's it's it's really sweet and it
brings tears to my eyes
it's also a gloomy as fuck movie like
they knew how to do both the others also
knows how to do better you can do both
and I get the need that's why I'm okay
with Luke living I'm like you don't have
to kill everybody you don't have to like
you need you needed something and that
apology to Nell was so needed because
cuz if fellow ever works
yeah everything was meaning to that and
the way she said nobody listened to me
and listen it you need that but to
execute it in or even like the ending to
a I I feel like could have been
rewritten in such a way where they would
work but to do it like that where David
never had a birthday like that's where
it loses me I'm like even the actor
in that scene or they have a little like
they just look like I can't believe
we're doing this like just after all the
other scenes they shot just like is this
really how we're fucking ending and I'm
sure there'll be so many making the
argument about a ho no it's really
secretly super creepy if you really
think but it does not come off that way
I have about AI all the time this new
haunting no but even this new haunting
they might be like well if you really
think about it's like just like the
ending to AI is really creepy if you
think about how it's a bunch of robots
or just wishfully and he's and I'm just
like yeah but the way it was executed
didn't work sorry does not yeah so yeah
there it is uh as you can tell by how
long this video is we some of we love
the haunting some of the shit out of
them the best horror I've ever seen in
this show I don't know what to tell you
though the ending it's I'll probably
never come to grips with it I'll just
I'll just be like listen like watch it
for the first nine episodes but if
you're like does it work as a whole it's
like I don't know if I'll ever be able
to say like it's so just I mean it
starts all clumsy totally loses it at
the end but the majority got very much
ya know obviously that's what I don't at
least not yet I don't have a desire to
watch this again because I'm like it's
not scary to me anymore
I again it's still scary to me because
the idea is so creepy and there's no out
but with the out now I don't know if it
scares me a 6 I'll probably be fine like
to really analyze how they gotten the
the shots the acting how maybe I'll
watch if somebody else hasn't seen it
because it's always fun yeah but yeah
hey I don't know I don't I don't have
that overriding desire yet cuz I'm just
like and it's all fine I'll work so I'm
not scared by that like yeah so yes -
well it's guess they still highly
recommend it but if you're watching at
this point yeah Whaley you must have
seen the show but go see it just be
forewarned yeah but yeah like I said we
we love the haunting just had
do a video talking about this show
because the people say this we've been
born we were gonna get into it cuz I
like to France and before that we did
get really for people thump up me for
saying I'm a hater up until episode 10
if you went 1 through 9 I honestly
thought and I know you say apples and
oranges but the themes of deals with on
par with the original film I have no
guilt saying that it does things
different some of the scares are in your
face and schlocky but these things in
the 63 film I have trouble with some of
the inner monologues and stuff and like
you know not every film is absolutely
but I was like I am completely on par so
this is not mean like witty snacky
originally it's just like it was so good
and so it's something to and then just
right at the end yeah we're we're all
about the morbid here man or if you're
gonna have it sweet have it be
bittersweet sorry
yeah assholes we are but that that's why
we love the original haunting because it
is such good characters that the scares
are mostly psychological and even than
this one they do manifest they're mostly
done well they at least match the
emotion of what's going on with the
characters even though it was scare us
all the time extremely impressed yeah so
that's again that's why that
disappointment was so powerful because I
was so unborn yeah and I'm just glad oh
no uncle I just people are kind of
knowing what the haunting is because all
they had was that shitty 99 remake and
it's kind of people are going back now
seeing the blanket while I just connect
the black and white we don't regret this
coming out and I hope this leads to more
things like it just with a better ending
yeah so that's what other you guys we'll
see you later
bye
you